welcome back we're here with the
incredible hair stylist and my dear
friend chris appleton who's been giving
us
a makeover to one of our viewers all
hour long and before we get to that big
reveal we want to check in with another
couple in our audience sebastian and
michael
hi guys
hi hi drew i feel like we've been like
catching eyes the whole show absolutely
i love how you're like leaning in and
your energy i've been picking up on it
but what have you guys picked up on from
each other
so we learned fairly early on that we
both are into travel although that's not
really been
too easy to do lately no but that's a
common
that's a commonality we like that yep
yeah and then we talked about what we've
traveled for and what we're going to
travel to and then that brought us to
like you know the typical homosexual
conversation topic of female pop stars
and then we notice that each of our
phone lock screens is our favorite pop
star so that was that was a fun moment
yeah who's who um kylie minogue for me
and christina aguilera over here i mean
okay
this is going well gorgeous divas are
you guys gonna go out on a date we've
got skydiving what are you guys are you
guys gonna do something i was thinking
maybe we'd go to fiji with the other
couple
all right well i think you guys should
bond over a cocktail
and um and uh and we have one for you
it's called tea drops they're actually
um bagless tea blends that are like a
bath bomb of tea that dissolves in your
cup and they're sending you and our
entire audience home with a hundred
dollar tea drops gift card
[Applause]
okay chris we're so excited because
earlier we met iris
and she's
looking for a fresh start coming out of
30-year marriage yep um are you guys all
ready to see iris
i am
all right iris come on out
i feel so glamorous
i feel like i'm dreaming is this me i
looked in their mirror i'm like who is
this girl
come on give us a spin give him the full
thing there she goes
okay
i know my jaw it actually hurts i'm like
shut shut this jaw
and you don't seem like the same person
no i agree
see with the see even in that picture
you can see her shoulders the way she's
kind of hunched over more and then now
how her shoulders go back more confident
that's what a good haircut and a little
makeover can do to it makes you feel
like you want to stand up taller you
know you feel like you're you're proud
to be in the room you know
how do you feel iris i feel great i just
i can't believe this is so
transformational for me i didn't expect
this at all it's like a little bit of a
makeover but this is drastic for me and
i feel great so chic sophisticated
glamorous um so iris you are sporting
that empowerment food
thank you
thank you so much
your team is great are you open to
dating are you to go on a date how are
you feeling maybe i don't know we'll see
but i love that attitude too because you
know like we've said this there's lots
of loving yourself it starts with having
that relationship with yourself
i know that from being single and
working on it myself you know it takes
time to be comfortable with yourself and
doing things for you that's a great
feeling because then i think when you
get to that point is when you're ready
to go out there so it is your time now i
was
to be in a relationship with yourself
and when you want to date here and there
because dating is totally fun and should
not be off the menu
you look phenomenal thank you and you
should go into a complete conference
before we go we have a surprise for you
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]